Générique
- Alexandre Poussart:
Bonjour à tous.
Heureux de vous retrouver
dans "Parlement hebdo", l'émission
qui revient sur l'actualité
de la semaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder: Avec nous
aujourd'hui, Rachid Temal.
Vous êtes sénateur socialiste
du Val-d'Oise.
Trois actualités
à la une pour vous.
- Alexandre Poussart: L'examen de
la réforme des retraites commence
à l'Assemblée nationale en
commission, avec 7000 amendements
déposés, dont 6000 de la part des
députés de gauche.
Le projet de loi sur les Jeux
Olympiques Paris 2024 examiné au
Sénat.
La majorité de droite a validé les
mesures concernant la sécurité de
l'événement, et notamment
l'expérimentation de la vidéo
augmentée pour surveiller les
foules.
Les députés et les sénateurs ont
trouvé un accord sur le projet de
loi qui accélère le développement
des énergies renouvelables.
Les élus locaux auront désormais
leur mot à dire dans
l'implantation des éoliennes sur
leur territoire.
- Kathia Gilder: La réforme des
retraites est arrivée à
l'Assemblée nationale.
Les députés vont scruter chaque
point du projet de loi de finances
rectificative du budget de la
Sécurité sociale.
C'est le texte qui contient la
réforme.
Voyons quels sont les différents
groupes et leurs positions.
- Une réforme des retraites dans
tous les esprits.
Dans la majorité, on tente de
déminer certains sujets, comme la
question des femmes.
- Je ne peux pas laisser dire que
notre projet ne protégerait pas
les femmes.
Nous demandons à celles et ceux
qui le peuvent de travailler
progressivement plus longtemps, y
compris des femmes qui ont eu des
carrières complètes.
Cependant, les femmes continueront
à partir plus tôt que les hommes.
Les femmes bénéficieront de
meilleures pensions.
- A gauche, les groupes de la
NUPES affinent leur stratégie:
déposer des amendements, mais sans
faire forcément d'obstruction.
Objectif: aller au moins jusqu'au
vote de l'article 7, celui sur le
report de l'âge légal.
- On veut que le débat ait lieu
sur l'article 7, qui est le
rallongement de deux ans.
On ne veut pas que le gouvernement
utilise le faible temps de parole
pour ne pas discuter du coeur de
la réforme, qui est à cet article
sur le report de deux ans.
- Le RN entend marquer son
opposition ferme à la réforme,
mais sans vouloir le chaos dans
l'hémicycle ni appeler à la
mobilisation dans la rue.
Et la droite, dans tout ça?
Les 62 députés Les Républicains
sont les arbitres de la réforme,
mais apparaissent chaque jour un
peu plus divisés.
Top départ de l'examen en
commission des Affaires sociales,
lundi 30 janvier, et en séance
dans l'hémicycle, lundi 6 février.
- Kathia Gilder: Nous sommes avec
Rachid Temal, président délégué du
groupe socialiste au Sénat.
7241 amendements ont été déposés à
l'Assemblée nationale, plus de
6000 venus des oppositions.
Dans la majorité, certains
réclament aussi de revoir et de
corriger le texte.
Est-ce que vous croyez qu'il est
encore possible d'améliorer cette
réforme présentée par le
gouvernement?
- Rachid Temal: Il faut d'abord
dire pourquoi il y a cette
réforme.
Le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites l'a dit lui-même lors
d'une audition à l'Assemblée
nationale: il n'y a pas de
nécessité de réformer le système.
On a le droit de dire qu'il n'y a
pas de nécessité.
Pourtant, cela fait des semaines
que le gouvernement nous dit qu'il
y a péril en la demeure.
La seule réforme qui serait
aujourd'hui envisageable et
sérieuse, c'est améliorer le
système.
Aujourd'hui, l'homme qui a retiré
la pénibilité de la retraite,
c'est Emmanuel Macron.
Il faut remettre la pénibilité.
Il y a aussi la question du
différentiel hommes-femmes.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a beaucoup
d'amendements.
- Rachid Temal: Quand vous rentrez
dans la mécanique, il faut y
rentrer.
Il n'y a aucune nécessité de faire
cette réforme aujourd'hui.
C'est un texte budgétaire.
Ce que propose Macron aujourd'hui,
c'est, à terme, de maintenir le
montant de la pension globale,
donc c'est une régression.
La réforme que nous connaissons en
France a toujours permis
d'améliorer les pensions.
Aujourd'hui, les retraités sont de
plus en plus pauvres.
Avec cette réforme, vous aurez une
retraite d'autant plus précaire.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il y a une
solution proposée par les députés
d'opposition: un référendum avec
le dépôt d'une motion
référendaire.
Est-ce que ça peut être une sortie
à ce débat sur la réforme des
retraites?
- Rachid Temal: La vraie sortie,
ce serait plutôt de retirer la
réforme.
Franck Riester lui-même a expliqué
que pour les femmes, ce serait
encore plus pénible.
Ce n'est pas sérieux.
Quand on parle de ce qui se passe
dans les EHPAD, à l'occasion de la
ressortie d'un bouquin, il
vaudrait mieux mettre de l'argent
et de l'énergie à faire en sorte
que dans les EHPAD, les gens qui
sont dans le grand âge puissent
mieux vivre plutôt que d'aller
faire une réforme qui est une
régression sociale.
- Kathia Gilder: Vos collègues à
l'initiative, les députés
communistes, vont faire une
motion.
Ce n'est pas forcément gagné pour
le gouvernement.
- Rachid Temal: Je soutiens mes
collègues, ce n'est pas le sujet.
Quand vous êtes parlementaire,
vous faites avec les outils qui
sont à votre disposition.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que cette
motion a des chances de passer?
- Rachid Temal: J'entends bon
nombre d'élus de la majorité
présidentielle relative à
l'Assemblée et certains du MoDem,
et quand je les entends, je me dis
qu'ils sont en majorité relative,
donc ils ont une possibilité.
Mais en tant que responsable
politique que je suis, je dis au
gouvernement d'arrêter cela, qui
n'a aucun sens et qui va juste
paupériser les Français, après
l'allocation chômage qui a
paupérisé 9 millions de Français.
Cette réforme est une régression
sociale qui n'a aucun sens et
aucun fondement, comme le démontre
le président du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
les sénateurs socialistes vont
proposer des améliorations de la
réforme, notamment sur la
situation des femmes, qui seraient
plus impactées par le report de
l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite?
- Rachid Temal: Les élus
socialistes, nous étions dans la
rue à l'initiative des syndicats,
et j'invite tous à nouveau ce
mardi massivement.
De semaine en semaine, on voit que
le nombre de Français qui
s'opposent à cette réforme ne
cesse de croître.
Après, si la réforme devait venir
au Sénat, nous ferons des
propositions, évidemment.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le rôle du
Parlement, à savoir d'amender les
textes, de voter quand il faut
voter et de s'opposer quand il
faut s'opposer.
- Kathia Gilder: Les mesures sur
la pénibilité seront prises par
décret.
Est-ce que pour vous, c'est
acceptable?
- Rachid Temal: Ce qu'il y a de
pire, il est sûr de le faire
voter, et ce qu'il y a de moins
bien, on verra plus tard.
Comment croire ces gens-là, qui
ont retiré la pénibilité?
Quand Emmanuel Macron a été élu
président, il a retiré la
pénibilité.
Comment puis-je croire quelqu'un
qui a déjà fait le contraire de ce
qu'il est en train de dire?
Les Français ne sont pas dupes et
ont de la mémoire.
Ce gouvernement est celui qui a
durci la vie du travail des
Français et qui propose de durcir
la vie de la retraite.
La retraite, c'est la vie en bonne
santé.
Vous pouvez vivre après 30 ou 40
ans de travail.
On peut partir de cela.
Quand vous avez des différences de
six à neuf ans entre un ouvrier et
un cadre en terme de vie en bonne
santé à la retraite, il faut
partir de cela.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous parlez de
l'espérance de vie.
- Rachid Temal: En bonne santé.
Ce n'est pas la même chose.
Il faut faire tout le débat dans
l'autre sens si on part de là.
Il y a aussi le travail des
seniors.
Moins d'un senior sur deux, au
moment de son départ à la
retraite, est encore dans
l'emploi.
La perspective que l'on donne à
nos seniors, c'est qu'ils ont
travaillé des années durant et
qu'ils vont terminer aux minima
sociaux, et maintenant, on leur
dit qu'ils vont prendre deux ans
de plus.
Il faudrait garder les seniors
dans l'emploi.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il faut
sanctionner les entreprises qui
n'embauchent pas assez de seniors?
- Rachid Temal: Il faut déjà se
dire que c'est une priorité plutôt
que de détruire la retraite.
Il faut mettre tous les acteurs
autour de la table.
Je suis pour le dialogue social,
pour le compromis social.
Les syndicats d'employeurs et les
syndicats de salariés pourraient
se mettre autour de la table pour
travailler sur ces questions.
Dans ces cas-là, on n'aurait pas
cette fin de vie dégradante, sans
dignité.
On ne peut pas imaginer que les
gens terminent au chômage, aux
minima sociaux, après avoir donné
toutes ces années à la
collectivité.
Ce sont de vrais sujets.
Ca m'importe plus que d'essayer de
reculer l'âge, seulement pour des
mesures budgétaires.
- Kathia Gilder: Il faut donc
demander au gouvernement de
retirer cette réforme que vous
estimez injuste.
- Rachid Temal: Cette régression
sociale, si je puis me permettre.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est donc votre
position.
Mardi prochain, lors de la
prochaine journée de mobilisation,
vous serez dans le cortège.
Si les grèves continuent à monter
et si le blocage se fait sentir
dans le secteur de l'énergie,
est-ce que vous pensez qu'au vu de
ces éléments, le gouvernement peut
plier?
Est-ce que vous pensez que le
blocage dans les raffineries et la
grève peuvent faire plier le
gouvernement?
- Rachid Temal: Il y a déjà eu une
tentative de réforme des retraites
qui a été retirée par le
gouvernement d'Edouard Philippe à
l'époque.
C'était sous la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron.
- Kathia Gilder: C'était en pleine
crise sanitaire.
- Rachid Temal: Je rappelle qu'il
y a aussi une crise économique et
sociale actuellement.
Il ne reste plus que la lumière
aux Français aux 15 du mois dans
les frigos.
Aujourd'hui, c'est toujours la
crise.
Soit le gouvernement entend ce que
disent les Français, qui sont
majoritairement opposés à cette
réforme...
- Kathia Gilder: Vous pensez
qu'ils vont l'entendre?
- Rachid Temal: Je vais prendre un
exemple concret.
Ils ont essayé toute la semaine de
nous expliquer, sur la question de
la retraite des femmes, et on n'a
pas compris.
La seule personne qui n'a pas
compris la réforme, c'est Franck
Riester, puisque c'est lui qui a
dit ça.
Même au sein du gouvernement, il y
a des difficultés.
Il faut raison garder.
Il faut plutôt relancer l'économie
et permettre aux gens d'avoir un
meilleur niveau de vie.
Ce n'est pas cette réforme qui y
contribuera.
Il faut donc la retirer et mettre
plus de moyens
sur d'autres sujets comme la
sécurité, l'école, les EHPAD.
- Alexandre Poussart: Dans cette
contestation, est-ce qu'Anne
Hidalgo est dans son droit quand
elle dit que ce mardi, elle va
fermer la mairie de Paris pour
protester contre la réforme des
retraites?
- Rachid Temal: La maire de Paris
est aussi employeur.
Elle a le droit, comme tout
individu, comme tout élu, comme
tout Français, d'avoir un
mouvement et de dire qu'elle est
opposée.
Dans mon département, j'ai un
maire LR.
Il est contre cette réforme.
Il dit que jusqu'à ce que ça
s'arrête, il n'a plus de relations
avec l'Etat.
Il est aussi dans son droit.
Pas de polémique inutile
là-dessus.
Anne Hidalgo a raison de faire
cela, de dire qu'elle est opposée
à cette réforme et de permettre
aux salariés qui le souhaitent de
manifester et de faire cette
manifestation symbolique.
- Alexandre Poussart: Certains
socialistes défendent la réforme
pour une retraite à 60 ans, alors
que d'autres sont pour le maintien
à la retraite à 62 ans.
Vous reconnaissez qu'il y a une
division au sein des
parlementaires socialistes sur
cette question des retraites?
- Rachid Temal: Le seul texte que
je connais parle du départ à 62
ans.
Je suis pour l'intégration massive
des questions de pénibilité.
Soit les gens ont les 40 annuités,
soit on considère que la
pénibilité est telle qu'ils
peuvent partir plus tôt.
Il ne faut pas être dogmatique.
Quand vous regardez les syndicats,
il faut les entendre, sur la
pénibilité.
La position du PS, c'est celle-là.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous n'incarnez
pas une autre ligne que celle qui
existe actuellement au sein des
députés socialistes, qui ont été
élus sur la base de l'accord avec
la NUPES?
- Rachid Temal: Vous me parlez
d'un accord électoral, pas de
problème.
Chez mes collègues de l'Assemblée,
je n'ai pas entendu de dissonance
avec ceux du Sénat.
Que ce soit au Sénat ou à
l'Assemblée, il y a de la
diversité.
Vous verrez les débats.
Il y a une diversité, chez nous.
Ce qui compte, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui, nous disons que la
réforme proposée par le
gouvernement est une régression
sociale, et nous sommes tous
opposés à cette réforme à 64 ans.
- Alexandre Poussart: Donc il n'y
a pas de fracture politique qui se
ressentirait au sein des
parlementaires socialistes?
- Rachid Temal: Il y a une unité
totale des socialistes dans leur
ensemble sur l'opposition à cette
régression sociale proposée par le
gouvernement.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va
maintenant parler des Jeux
Olympiques Paris 2024.
Le projet de loi qui prépare
l'organisation de l'événement a
été étudié cette semaine, avec
notamment des mesures sur la
sécurité qui ont fait débat.
- On pouvait penser à un texte
dédié au sport, mais il a surtout
été question de sécurité.
Lors de l'examen du projet de loi
sur les Jeux Olympiques à Paris en
2024, le principal débat a porté
sur l'introduction d'une nouvelle
technologie pour surveiller les
abords de l'événement planétaire.
Grâce à des algorithmes qui
traitent les images caméras de
surveillance, les forces de
sécurité pourraient
automatiquement détecter des
situations suspectes, mais pas
collecter des données
personnelles, promet le
gouvernement.
- Pas question pour le
gouvernement d'aller dans la
quatrième catégorie, qui est celle
de la reconnaissance faciale, mais
de se donner les moyens de
détecter le cas échéant des
mouvements de foule, un colis
abandonné, éventuellement des
armes longues...
- Mais pour les opposants, ce
nouveau dispositif va trop loin et
l'expérimentation va s'étaler sur
deux ans, jusqu'en 2025, soit bien
après les Jeux Olympiques.
- Une loi d'exception qui vise à
pérenniser un coup de canif
supplémentaire dans nos libertés
publiques.
Il faut se prémunir de tout
phénomène de banalisation de ces
technologies de plus en plus
intrusives.
- L'article prévoyant cette
expérimentation a finalement été
largement adopté.
Autre point de vigilance des
sénateurs: le nombre d'agents de
sécurité disponibles pour les JO.
Il en faudra 22.000 selon les
organisateurs.
Interrogé sur le sujet, le
ministre de l'Intérieur n'a pas
totalement exclu le recours à
l'armée, mais seulement en dernier
recours.
- Si à la fin des fins, il manque
un certain nombre de personnes,
nous regarderons ce qu'il faut
faire.
Mais un grand pays comme la France
est capable de répondre
à cet enjeu de sécurité.
- Le Sénat a aussi noté une
augmentation des peines contre les
militants qui s'introduisent sur
les terrains de sport.
Autant de mesures qui doivent être
définitivement votées mardi par le
Sénat, avant que le texte ne soit
transmis à l'Assemblée nationale.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Contrairement à vos autres
collègues sénateurs de gauche, les
sénateurs socialistes ne sont pas
opposés à l'expérimentation de la
vidéo augmentée via des
algorithmes pour surveiller les
foules pendant cet événement, et
même après.
Pourquoi vous ne craignez pas des
risques pour nos libertés?
- Rachid Temal: Mes collègues ont
dit des choses.
Le texte JO n'a de JO que le nom.
C'est un texte sur des mesures
sécuritaires.
La France a déjà su organiser de
grands événements.
C'est une bonne chose.
Ce que nous disons à ce stade,
puisque la position du groupe sera
arrêtée mardi, et en tant que
président délégué, je ne peux pas
vous dire quel sera notre vote
puisqu'on aura un débat...
- Alexandre Poussart: Sur les JO,
vous vous êtes quand même abstenu.
Sur le vote final.
- Rachid Temal: On prend tous les
éléments.
Il y a des remarques de la CNIL,
déjà.
Nous disons qu'il s'agit d'abord
de temps.
Le gouvernement veut étaler cette
expérimentation au-delà des JO.
Il faut faire un bilan à la fin
des JO en rassemblant tous les
acteurs, notamment la CNIL.
Ensuite, il faut savoir ce que
l'on fait de ces données.
C'est un débat qui a été posé dans
l'hémicycle.
Mes collègues sont intervenus.
On prendra une position définitive
ce mardi pour savoir ce qu'on en
fait.
C'est un débat plus large.
C'est une vieille histoire.
C'est le débat entre la sécurité,
qui est le droit le plus
élémentaire, et la liberté
individuelle.
C'est pour ça qu'il faut plus que
jamais avoir des positions très
claires sur ce sujet.
- Kathia Gilder: Gérald Darmanin a
laissé entendre qu'il n'excluait
pas de recourir à la fin des fins
à l'armée.
Est-ce que c'est vraiment le rôle
des militaires d'assurer le
service d'ordre des JO?
- Rachid Temal: Ce n'est pas le
rôle des militaires.
Moi qui suis membre de la
commission des Affaires
étrangères, on ne peut pas tout
demander aux militaires.
Il y a des théâtres d'opérations
sur lesquels nous intervenons.
- Kathia Gilder: Donc ce n'est pas
forcément leur rôle d'être là?
- Rachid Temal: Il y a aussi des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
sur le territoire national.
Là aussi, c'est une vraie
question.
Je ne m'interdis rien.
Ne soyons pas dogmatiques.
Je considère que, pour reprendre
les mots du ministre de
l'Intérieur, que comme on est une
grande nation comme la France, on
est en capacité d'avoir 22.000
personnels formés en capacité
d'assurer la sécurité.
- Alexandre Poussart: Ce texte
crée de nouveaux délits pour les
personnes qui s'introduisent sans
billet à l'intérieur d'un stade.
On a en mémoire le fiasco de ce
match Real-Liverpool au Stade de
France l'année dernière.
- Rachid Temal: Il ne faut pas
tout mélanger.
Les JO, c'est une belle fête.
Je suis fier quand mon pays est en
capacité d'être sur le devant de
la scène internationale,
d'accueillir un bel événement.
Il faut que tout le monde soit
fier de cela.
Il faut qu'on y contribue.
Après, ne mélangeons pas tout.
Je considère que dans un stade, ne
peuvent y pénétrer que ceux qui
ont un billet.
C'est une bonne chose.
Ne tombons pas dans la caricature.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous n'êtes pas
inquiet quand vous voyez l'état
des transports en région
parisienne?
Vous pensez que tout sera prêt
pour accueillir les JO en toute
sécurité et sans chaos?
- Rachid Temal: Je suis dans
l'opposition.
Je me suis opposé à madame
Pécresse, qui est responsable des
transports depuis 2015 à la région
Ile-de-France.
Elle avait promis la révolution
des transports.
C'est aujourd'hui la régression
dans les transports.
C'est très inquiétant.
Je suis inquiet.
Malheureusement, ni madame
Pécresse, ni LR, ni ce
gouvernement avec monsieur Macron,
n'ont su régler le problème des
transports.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a aussi le
rôle d'Anne Hidalgo qui est pointé
du doigt.
Parce qu'on est quand même à
Paris.
- Rachid Temal: L'organisation des
transports dépend de la région.
J'ai bien compris que tout le
monde veut tout mettre sur le dos
de madame Hidalgo, mais elle n'a
rien à se reprocher sur les
transports.
Elle finance comme les autres,
mais celle qui organise les
transports, c'est madame Pécresse.
Donc ne faisons pas de faux débat.
- Alexandre Poussart: Dernier
sujet.
On va parler d'énergie.
Les sénateurs et les députés se
sont mis d'accord cette semaine
sur une version commune du projet
de loi qui accélère le développement
des énergies renouvelables.
Ce texte simplifie les procédures
administratives, accélère le
déploiement de l'éolien en mer,
libère du foncier pour installer
des panneaux solaires
au bord des routes.
Après l'examen au Parlement, le
rôle des élus locaux a été
renforcé dans l'implantation et le
choix des zones pour développer
notamment les éoliennes.
Cet accord transpartisan, la
ministre de la Transition
énergétique Agnès Pannier-Runacher
s'en est réjouie cette semaine.
- On a pu montrer qu'on était
capable, sur un sujet qui était
historiquement très sensible, de
dégager un accord, qui est au
rendez-vous de l'histoire.
C'est d'abord un gain de temps.
Je prends l'exemple de l'éolien
marin.
Les mesures que nous prenons vont
nous permettre de gagner plusieurs
années sur les projets.
C'est aussi une méthode de
planification qui remet les élus
de terrain au centre du jeu, qui
leur permet de définir les zones
où ils veulent installer des
énergies renouvelables, et
lorsqu'ils le font, des zones où
ils ne souhaitent pas qu'il y ait
d'énergies renouvelables.
Et puis, ce sont des engagements
et une accélération pour mettre
des panneaux photovoltaïques, là
où nous avons déjà artificialisé
les sols, ou bien là où les sols
sont dégradés, le long des routes,
sur le littoral, sur des anciennes
décharges, sur des parkings, sur
les toitures.
C'est vraiment une accélération de
nos capacités à produire de
l'électricité bas carbone.
- Alexandre Poussart: Les
parlementaires socialistes sont
les seuls à avoir voté pour ce
texte énergies renouvelables.
Ca veut dire qu'on peut être
constructif avec le gouvernement
et que les socialistes ont
toujours été pour une énergie
décarbonée?
- Rachid Temal: Nous avons
toujours été pour une énergie
décarbonée, chez les socialistes.
Le rôle de la navette
parlementaire a été assuré.
Nous aurions aimé commencer par un
débat sur la politique énergétique
française avant tout.
On a fait ça à l'envers.
Nous, les socialistes, c'est notre
position depuis toujours, nous
sommes pour le mix énergétique.
- Kathia Gilder: La part du
nucléaire doit représenter 50% du
mix énergétique, hors les
sénateurs ont voté un autre texte
qui vise à accélérer...
- Rachid Temal: Des sénateurs de
droite!
- Kathia Gilder: Cet objectif de
50% de mix énergétique a été
dénoncé par les sénateurs de
droite.
Vous pensez que ce sera rétabli à
l'Assemblée?
- Rachid Temal: Il faut un débat
entre pays.
Je crois que ça passera par cette
fameuse loi qui nous est promise.
Il y a un sujet de politique
nationale française en général.
Il y a aussi la question des
outils.
Est-ce qu'il y a des opérateurs
publics?
On commence à l'envers.
Il fallait commencer par la
politique et les objectifs.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est une
question de timing?
- Rachid Temal: Tout le monde peut
comprendre.
On ne commence pas par construire
un moyen de transport avant de
savoir où on va.
Il faut qu'on ait ce débat.
- Alexandre Poussart: Pour
conclure sur ce sujet, quand on
prend un peu de recul et que l'on
voit nos fragilités en termes
d'approvisionnement énergétique,
est-ce que ça n'a pas été une
erreur du gouvernement socialiste
et des écologistes de limiter le
développement de l'énergie
nucléaire et de fermer Fessenheim?
- Rachid Temal: Il n'y a pas eu de
limitation.
On ne peut pas dire à la fois
qu'il faut faire ce mix et ne pas
prendre de décision.
On peut contester des décisions.
Ce qui est clair, c'est que nous,
en France, on permet de développer
les énergies renouvelables.
Si on ne touche jamais à rien et
que ça reste de simples discours,
ça marche pas.
A titre personnel, je suis pour le
nucléaire.
Je n'ai pas de soucis avec ça.
- Alexandre Poussart: On finit
avec l'agenda de la semaine
prochaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder: Lundi marquera le
coup d'envoi de la discussion du
projet de loi sur les retraites en
commission des Affaires sociales,
avant l'examen en séance publique
prévue le 6 février.
Le président de l'assemblée
d'Ukraine sera à l'Assemblée
nationale mardi avant les
questions d'actualité.
Il fera un discours devant les
députés.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il sera
également devant les sénateurs
mercredi, et la veille, le Sénat
débattra de la proposition de loi
dite anti squat contre
l'occupation illicite de
logements, avant d'examiner la
proposition de loi qui introduit
le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution, un texte venu de
l'Assemblée nationale et qui avait
fait l'objet d'une alliance entre
la majorité présidentielle et la
gauche.
C'est la fin de cette émission.
Merci d'avoir été notre invité,
Rachid Temal.
- Kathia Gilder: A la semaine
prochaine.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA